[موسيقى]
هل ستسقط مبلغًا كبيرًا أو أكثر على
أحدث هاتف iPhone لأول مرة في
تاريخ الهاتف الذكي الذي يمتد لعشر سنوات ،
وتوقع المحللون أن Apple أطلقت ثلاثة
طرز مختلفة ويعتقدون أن
الطراز الأغلى سيكلف
1000 دولار أمريكي.  - بالنسبة
للمنافسين مثل Samsung الذين لديهم بالفعل
شاشات قريبة من الحافة ، يُشاع أن أحدث هاتف iPhone
يتمتع بتصميم مشابه مع
انتقال الشاشة من الحافة إلى الحافة
وقد يصبح وجهك كلمة المرور الخاصة بك ،
حيث تتخلف Apple عن
منافسيها ، مما يتيح لك التعرف على الوجه
لإلغاء قفل هاتفك وإجراء
مدفوعات ، نأمل ألا يتم
خداع ذلك بسهولة مثل Samsung Note 8 حيث أن
الأشخاص يدخلون بمجرد صورة
لمالك الهاتف ، وقد يكون أكبر متاعب هو إعادة
تعلم كيفية استخدام جهاز iPhone الخاص بك.
زر الصفحة الرئيسية نحن
معتادون أيضًا على استبداله
بشريط رقمي وطريقة أخرى يمكن أن يقوم بها iPhone
بالشحن اللاسلكي
لمجموعة كاملة من طرازات Samsung alre  ady
مشحونة من خلال قواعد الشحن اللاسلكية وأخذت Apple
صفحة من snapchat مما قد يلحق
بالواقع ، لذا فإن
مجموعة AR الحديثة من Apple موجودة بالفعل في أيدي
المطورين الذين يأملون في
أن يتم تصميم كاميرا على iPhone القادم
خصيصًا باستخدام مستشعر ليزر لصنعها
تبدو مرشحات الصور الشخصية الشهيرة هذه
أكثر واقعية بالنسبة
لك